you know i don't like to think in terms
of opportunities at this point i would
put it at least in my area more in terms
of
the biggest challenge that we faced over
the next decade
i've dealt with international affairs in
my career now for about
25 or 30 years and we were in the midst
of one of the historic global
transformations
that is going to eventually lead to a
new world order the shape of that we
don't know at this point but we know
the processes that are underway it's
commonplace now to talk about the shift
in global dynamism
from the europe atlantic region to asia
and the pacific region
we've seen the the turmoil of the tomat
in the
in the arab world that started a couple
of years ago
but we also know that the whole notion
of power in the international system is
changing
before we talk mainly in terms of
military power we know economic power is
much more important now
soft power has become a very popular and
almost vogus
topic to talk about now we've also seen
that the fundamental building block of
our international system the sovereign
state
you see it under stress from
supernational organizations
sub-regional organizations terrorist
groups
uh transnational corporations
transnational non-governmental
organizations
and so forth we're seeing now that
because of globalization
there is a tension between
global processes and national regulation
we see that most
uh vividly in financial flows uh that
move around the globe almost
instantaneously because of the
uh of the internet and yet it's still
regulated largely by international
or excuse me national national regimes
and finally we've seen globalization
the rise of new technologies lead to
a an adjusting of the balance between
state and society
i think the most vividly uh right now in
in the middle east uh and so
a massive global transformation and all
these forces all these developments are
going to play themselves out over the
next decade
and the question is whether we can turn
this challenge into an opportunity
because there is an opportunity to take
these various forces
and build a new world order that will
help create and sustain peace
prosperity and justice well into the
21st century